welcome back I hope you had a good lunch
and a good opportunity to network or
meet some of the other folks here who
are in attendance today I'm going to try
to keep the great level of presentations
we've had already and not reduce it to
too much in terms of quality because the
presentations have been really
phenomenal I hope you're all enjoying
them and if you're not just don't say
anything in response I'm sure I'm sure
you are and there's a lot certainly to
be gained from listening to our terrific
speakers we've had already I have a sort
of a different topic to talk about to
kick us off this afternoon one that's I
guess a little bit more social than it
is just based on decisions alone and
I'll start by just sharing a story when
I was just graduate from college I
worked as a social worker in a homeless
Center in downtown Oakland and it was
actually a pretty pretty hard job I
found it pretty challenging but I was
also partly inspired by the work that
was done there and thought about two
options you know pursuing a PhD seemed
like strange alternative or pursuing a
career and an administration for Human
Services and so in part of my search I
talked to a couple different individuals
who were executive directors of some
local nonprofit organizations and Human
Services and one of the questions I
remember asking them at the end was you
know what is it what did you what did
you find surprising about this career
path that you didn't expect would be so
important or such a such a big aspect of
it when you originally got down this
this path and both of them mentioned one
much more sort of vociferous lis than
the other mentioned this one particular
thing which I thought was really
interesting they said well in this kind
of job you really have to be okay with
asking people for stuff because a lot of
what you do is you ask people for stuff
you know whether it's asking people for
charitable donations of course or asking
people who work for you to do more for
less or asking other organizations to
cooperate with you to share resources
etc a lot of your job is often asking
for stuff and for some of us that's
harder than it is maybe for others in
particular for me so I chose an academic
career instead of going down that path
but I've always been interested in the
process of asking people for things and
so
I've done some work on the experience of
asking others for stuff or asking others
for help asking others for a favor
whatever the case is and I can relate
this back to our current experience here
today at least my own experience because
to put this conference together one of
the things I had to do was ask these
presenters to come and present the day
which was really terrifying for me sort
of a nerve-racking experience because
I'm really asking them for a lot to be
here today
I mean as I'm thinking about the
experience all I can think of in my mind
of course is all the reasons they would
not do this so number one I'm asking
them to make a big trip take time out of
their day to travel in some cases across
the country to be here for a day or two
days what have you in addition of course
they have to do some work to put
together a presentation to share with
all of you while they're here and of
course finally they may be leaving
behind loved ones as well who it's hard
for them to sort of let go of or you
know have some detachment from so this
is a big ask certainly and I know just
the natural Calculus people sort of use
in thinking about these situations as a
course they're no doubt thinking about
well how likely is it somebody will say
yes when I ask them for something
because there may be all sorts of
reasons why they would say no and the
extent this matters because the extent
to which people feel like others are
likely to say yes they're much more
emboldened to ask but the extent to
which they feel like others are more
looking to say no of course they're much
less likely to ask no one likes to be
rejected so this becomes a very
fundamental social question an
interpersonal interaction because you
would assume naturally people are pretty
good at guessing or judging whether
others are likely to say yes when asked
for anything because few things one
we've got a lot of experience asking
people for stuff too we've had a lot of
experience being asked for stuff this is
one perspective taking instance where we
actually do know what it's like to be in
the other role and in addition to that
we have lots of incentives working
toward us being accurate one we want to
minimize the social cost of rejection we
want to maximize the instrumental
benefits of getting cooperation so
everything would point to us being
really good at this judgment
what I'll suggests along with a
colleague of mine Vanessa bonds who's
worked on all these studies with me at
the University of Toronto is that people
are actually really bad at this and
they're bad in one specific direction
which is they grossly underestimate how
likely people are to say yes when they
ask them for stuff that people are much
more likely to say yes than they think
despite having lots of experience having
asked people for things in many other
situations or cases and the reason that
is we suggest it's because the kind of
things we think about when deciding
whether to ask somebody for something
aren't necessarily the kind of things
that other people think about when
they're being asked I describe for you
what I was thinking about all those
things that I mentioned were sort of
like I don't know I guess I'd call it
you know the costs of saying yes that
they'd have to sort of bear all these
costs if they were come out here and
give this presentation but they could be
thinking about it much differently that
is they could be focusing on the cost of
saying no you know they want to think of
themselves as a generous person somebody
who's able to sort of come through on
requests etc and so they want are
motivated to say yes maybe there's some
benefit to saying yes you know some some
warm glow we get from helping others
whatever the case might be but that's
not what I'm thinking about often when
I'm thinking about asking people for
stuff so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to suggest that this generally
holds in most cases but there are some
cases where we can manipulate this
effect by changing up the types of
requests we're making the way in which
requests are made or the context in
which they're posed so I'm going to
start by walking through some
demonstrations some field demonstrations
of this underestimation effect the fact
that we underestimate how likely others
are to say yes to request for help and
in addition to that then I'll sort of
look at a field study which tries to
shed light on an underlying mechanism
for this effect why it actually happens
and then if I have time and hopefully
we'll move into some extensions looking
at cases where we're not only asking
people for help but we're asking people
who've rejected us previously for help
and seeing how accurate we are in
guessing whether they'll say yes in
those cases and then finally looking at
cases where we're not only sort of
looking at whether we're estimating
other's willingness to help but estimate
others willingness to seek help and see
how good we are judging that as well so
in each of these studies I'm going to
sort of walk through quickly what we do
what we set up is a real task where
people have to have to actually go out
and ask people for stuff so they come in
the lab and they're told listen this is
you know what you got to do we're you're
gonna have to go out on campus or go out
in the city and randomly or just
approach each person who happens to be
walking toward you and ask that person
for something but before you do that
we're going to ask you to make a guess
or an estimate about how many people you
got to ask before you can get X number
to agree to do it so they're going to
sort of make a judgment about how
willing others are on average to agree
to this simple request now we only do
this in about half the cases where we
have people make estimates just because
we don't want people's predictions to
affect their behaviors we want to test
to make sure that's not happening and in
fact we have plenty of evidence to
suggest that doesn't happen in this case
afterwards we of course compared their
predicted rate of compliance versus the
actual rate of compliance they
experienced now in this first case we
have them go through a pretty contrived
task in which we bring them in and we
say listen we want you to go out on
campus approach every person coming
you know closest to you and ask them if
they'd be willing to fill out a
questionnaire we show them the
questionnaire it's two pages long
relatively straightforward they've got a
clipboard with five questionnaires
they've got to get five people to agree
to do this before they can come back and
collect their money so before we send
them out we ask them how many people you
think are gonna have to approach before
you can get five to agree to do this and
I ask you this question in your mind
just come up with a number how many
people do you think you have to approach
before you can get five to agree to this
request this is New York City and
Columbia campus so just give you some
context and they're just sort of
randomly approaching these folks look at
that number in your mind actually that's
a pretty interesting number to have so
we asked them for this information they
go out they make these requests
encounter these folks sort of just
randomly and they're asked to follow a
script but they can only ask them excuse
me would you be willing to fill out a
questionnaire that's it and then see you
know how successful they are so in this
case we asked them to do this again they
got to get five people to agree
their predictions are as follows they
think it will take about 20 to 21 folks
on average they'll have to ask in order
to get five people to agree to this
request so in other words we're not
every four people will say yes in
reality every other person says yes one
out of every two every other person they
encounter says yes so they are grossly
under estimating how likely people are
to say yes when they ask them for stuff
which is interesting of course because
here's the favorite play game yes no
actually no so sorry I was weird
so here's the here's the funny thing one
of my colleagues Jeff Pfeffer really he
likes one particular aspect of this
study which he says is like in the
footnote but he loves it which is how
many people dropped out of this study
which was a big number like 20 percent
read the instructions and they're like
oh no I'm not doing that um I'm gonna go
do the marketing study instead for sure
because this is exactly because you know
this looks daunting there's no way
you're going to get by people to agree
to do this and just the sheer daunting
nature of the task was intimidating
enough to them imagine how high their
estimates would have been if they were
actually in the study so clearly people
grossly overestimating in this case but
this is a pretty contrived case I mean
how much experience do you have doing
something like this not much unless
you're a graduate student or an academic
looking to get people to fill out
surveys so some very nice reviewers of
this work suggested that we run
additional studies as they're inclined
to do often and in this case they looked
for one replications with realistic
requests I thought that was a great idea
so we thought of a couple different
requests one was imagine you were just
walking around campus and you needed to
borrow somebody's cell phone in this
case we want to get you to get three
people to allow you to borrow the cell
phone they have to then take the phone
call back to lab we can call our ID
their phone and check make sure they're
actually doing this so they have to go
out and do this task a third can study
we actually had the missus on Columbia
campus as well we put them in the middle
of campus and we had them approach
people and ask them if they'd give them
that escort to the campus gym if they'd
walk them to the campus gym this is
actually a pretty interesting request
because it's completely believable
because the Columbia gym is
Iranian very hard to find if you've
never been there before and it's about
three city blocks so it's a somewhat
significant request to to walk them over
there the other advantage of this
particular one was we had issues of
trust in our lab group about whether
people were really following along with
these instructions or whether they were
sort of picking out the softies who they
could see walking by who'd be more
likely to say yes and going for them so
we we had a we had a man in the bushes
basically for this task who is tracking
people and make sure they were actually
complying with the instructions which
which they were which was great so so we
send them out in this case they've got
to get us three to agree for the cell
phone request or just one to agree to
welcome to the campus gym now the
questionnaire situation they
overestimated in this case about two to
one they thought it'd take about twenty
to get five and we took about ten in the
cell phone case they got to get three
people to agree they think they're going
to have to ask of a little more than ten
people on average in reality they have
to ask six in order to get three to
agree in the case with walking them to
the gym they think they're going to have
to ask about seven or eight people on
average in reality every other person
says yes to they have to ask so huge
overestimation they're just how
difficult this task is going to be to
get somebody to agree to do this so
people think it's much less likely on
average that casual interactions with
strangers where you ask them for
something is going to lead to some
success this is one of my favorite
experiences of ever interacting with a
reviewer in the scholarly review process
because one of the viewers on this paper
relayed a story at the beginning of one
of his reviews in which he said thanks
very much for this paper because it
bailed me out of a recent situation I
had routes running late for dinner with
my in-laws and normally I would have
never had my phone on me I was at the
train station would never ask somebody
normally to borrow their phone but this
certainly made it seem made me feel more
emboldened to go ahead and save my
behind by calling ahead and letting them
know I was late it was a very collegial
moment like in the review process which
is great for for academics yeah right
then they don't want to reject the paper
directly but to be fair these are all of
course experimental studies which are
contrived
so I still wanted to find a situation
where there's a naturally occurring help
request and see whether or not even in
situations maybe where people aren't
strangers but they're familiar with each
other would you get the same general
effect because we could imagine that
you're not very good at judging somebody
you never met before but maybe you're
pretty good at judging people you know
quite well so we wound up working with
an organization called teaming training
how many people here know team and
training heard it before
that's pretty alright great so we got
maybe about 20% who don't so I'll just
explain really quickly what this
organization does so team and training
raises money for leukemia and lymphoma
research and the way they do that is
they enlist people who want to run a
marathon or a triathlon to raise money
on behalf of Leukemia Lymphoma Society
now you get in exchange some training
for your fundraising efforts
you get training from actually highly
qualified coaches and you also have the
social support of working toward this
goal with other people so we worked with
this organization in New York City in
their place there but we wanted races
around the country so we actually
selected people who were doing races in
Florida Chicago Washington and somewhere
else came over where just to get some
geographic variation because people were
also concerned about whether this was
really a New Yorkers art as bad as you
think bias in our in our studies so we
wanted some geographic variation so
what's nice about this particular
organization is that they also have
fundraising Diaries or fundraising logs
which we can track and make sure the
self-report data we're getting is
actually valid and not being manipulated
in some way that suggests some socially
desirable responding on the part of
participants in this case we recruited
people who just went to a seminar and
decided they were going to sign up for
Team in training and they could rate
they're going to be asked to raise a
significant amount of money anywhere
between $2,000 to five or six thousand
dollars that they have to raise to
participate in this race and they agreed
to sort of keep this fundraising diary
along the way tracking everybody they
asked everybody who comes through and
then we also have the actual results of
their fundraising from the organization
as well so it's really great context for
us to look at what we're studying
great also in a couple more respects
this is a really conservative test of
the hypothesis I just put forth think
about it from this perspective one these
are familiar others that these folks go
do to ask for stuff and they're asking
for money from people they know well
family and friends for the most part
make up the list of donors here for this
organization they're not random
strangers usually number two very
conservative test largely because the
folks who signed up are the ones who
thought they could do it the people who
didn't sign up were those who probably
thought it was far more daunting these
results would certainly be more likely
to be supported if we had those folks in
the sample but we don't we're just
looking at the people who actually
signed up for the study so in this case
we asked them all sorts of questions in
the beginning before they start the
fundraising process to see what their
estimates are like what their
expectations are like and when we asked
them you know how many people is going
to take for you to reach your
fundraising goal you know how many you
have to ask to reach that goal they
think it's going to take about 200 or so
asks 200 or so people they have to
approach and reality takes a little over
a hundred that they have to approach
again we're seeing this two to one ratio
a lot here which I'll come back to
perhaps later at the end but we also
asked them to make this prediction lots
of ways we asked them to make this
prediction also in terms of what
percentage of people will agree to make
a donation they think on average maybe
thirty percent of folks they asked will
make a donation in reality it's closer
to half the people they ask actually
make a donation and here's some funny
things because I really was intrigued by
these data I wanted to see if there were
things we could do to look at the
percentage of family and friends they
were asking would that make a difference
that when you're asking people you're
more familiar with you're better at
judging if they'll say yes no didn't
have an effect stranger versus friend
and family one interesting difference
was in this particular sample there are
people who sign up multiple times to do
team in training so about 15 percent of
the folks had done PMON training before
they had actually done even the past
year sometimes the same race so they
clearly had a lot of experience in this
particular role so we want to see in
this case what these folks are they
still likely to underestimate compliance
yes
they don't underestimate as much as the
pea
who's doing doing it for the first time
but they significantly underestimate how
likely others are to say yes you know
they just did this thing previously so
it seems like a pretty robust bias here
and of course what we're thinking is
well you know this could be really
useful and certainly that's why the
organization was willing to participate
with us because they also thought it
could be pretty useful you know what
they decided to do was to take the
results of our study and basically show
people the results when they were
thinking about signing up for Team in
training because you know they've run a
lot of these seminars and a lot of
people say that sounds great no way am i
signing up for that that looks really
hard I'm gonna have to do something else
with my volunteering or whatever the
case is or find some other way to
participate in this raise so what they
did is just decided if we show people
that this is going to be a lot easier
and you think of course they're going to
be more likely or more emboldened to
sign up because all that sort of were
enos worried worrying about being
rejected about sort of struggling
through this effort is going to be
dissipated to some extent but in
addition to that are also sort of
interested in whether or not our
explanation for why this happens
actually holds water in the sense that
my my take on it
is that when people are asking others
for help or assistance or a donation of
some sort they're really focusing on
like how big is this ask I mean what's
this what's the magnitude of this ask my
asking for a lot here or I'm asking for
a little and thinking about how likely
the person is to say yes but in many
cases it might be different for the
person on the other side what they're
thinking about is not the cost of saying
yes so much is the cost of saying no how
awkward would it be for me to say no
right now how you know sort of how bad
what I feel how uncomfortable would I
feel if I had to say no right now and I
don't factor that into my calculus as
the helpseeker or the person requesting
help and so we test this idea we went
yeah go ahead if you ask the veterans
how many people they asked in the last
campaign did they get it right so are
they do they miss remember how many
knows their word or they just think that
going forward it will be difficult know
what I'm saying so right because they
maybe have to say I got to go to like a
bunch of new people as opposed to go to
the same people I went to before
we don't know for sure because the
reality is they do go to a lot of same
people they went to before but we don't
know that's because they they were
thinking about going to some new people
but they said is going to be too hard I
very just go to the old people I went to
before so we don't know we can't rule
out that that's actually the process
they're going through as they're
thinking this is going to be a stranger
interaction but it turns out it's not a
stranger interaction don't have a good
answer for that when somebody says no
twice as bad as somebody saying yes
feels good right
so we're thinking back absolutely when I
asked you how many people you asked
you're getting it wrong but you're
actually accurately reporting your
emotional experience right so was Isis
bad absolutely that people misinterpret
that as being the number of people
rather than the pain of asking
absolutely so we in one case we've asked
people to sort of like recall episodes
of non-compliance vs. compliance and
they will write tomes
on the episodes of non-compliance and
what their reaction was like in that
situation or how painful it was
etc versus cases where people have said
yes I mean that's a it's a it's a
concern that we have that we sort of
maybe exaggerate in our minds like how
great these social costs are maybe
exaggerated in our minds we're so averse
to them you know we're really good at
convincing ourselves it would be so
terrible to encounter them so we wanted
to see if this explanation makes sense
so we went back to our original paradigm
of the questionnaire task from study one
and ran some manipulations in this case
a couple of manipulations that we ran
involve the size of the request as well
as the directness of the request so
rather than ask people fill out a
two-page questionnaire we asked them to
either fill out a one-page questionnaire
or a ten page questionnaire so really
small ask or a really big ask and turns
out much time to spend on this thing and
then we also manipulated whether they
were asking them directly would you fill
out this questionnaire or rather
indirectly by giving them a flyer that
has it written on it would you fill out
this questionnaire and wanted to see if
this affected people's expectations of
how successful these means of asking are
going to be and so well we we have them
go through this during again one of four
conditions either they're asking for a
small thing directly asking for a small
thing via flyer
asking for a big thing directly or
asking for a big thing via flyer so we
replicate our effect that we have the
direct request here people are assuming
it's going to take far more individuals
to get one person to agree than it
actually does by a significant margin
but the exact opposite is true when we
use the indirect request people think
that the flyer is going to be relatively
almost as effective as asking somebody
face-to-face but of course it's not it's
not even close for the most part people
take flyers and throw them away people
take emails and delete them people take
all sorts of indirect requests and they
ignore them pretty effectively but we
don't factor that in when we're making
predictions about how they're going to
behave because we're not very good at
judging house
I guess socially constrained somebody is
in choosing whether to act in the way we
want or not what's interesting is that
when we look at their estimates
according to the size of the requests
they're very sensitive to that so you
know their requests change according to
whether they're going to are their
estimates change according to whether
I'm asking them to collect one-page
questionnaires 10 page questionnaires I
think there's no way people are going to
fill out these ten page questionnaires
but in reality people are not that
significantly less likely to fill out a
10 page questionnaire versus a 1 page
questionnaire if they agree to one
they're actually pretty likely to agree
to the other and when we play this out
over the different conditions we see the
sort of pattern we expect that sort of
goes along with our explain our
psychological mechanism that the people
who are asking or thinking about the the
magnitude the requests how much is this
I have to ask for but the people are
being asked are thinking about how
awkward would this be to say no if it's
really direct it's going to be really
hard for me to say no it's very indirect
can be relatively easy for me to say no
now let's let's I guess take this into
context and think about how this can be
applied so I got a call once from this
guy who ran a campaign for food banks
for an organization called I think
Second Harvest and it was called check
out hunger
I think it's called and it's basically
you've probably seen these cards before
at grocery stores you walk up to
checkout and there's like three cards
usually on the left do you want to
donate a dollar three dollars five
dollars etc to go along with your
purchases to support the food banks
local food banks etc this was in upstate
New York programs weren't going great so
he wants some advice about you know how
to change it to make it more effective
and all his questions were asking me
about what's your the amounts be I'm you
know are we asking people for too much
here I mean as one dollar too much we
asking people for less maybe we should
be going pay-as-you-go or you know like
pay what you want you know there's
something about the magnitude of our
requests that's what's wrong and I said
you know just for my personal experience
I don't think that's it I think when I
go you know to check out my own
experience go in the grocery store I'm
almost never asked by the checkout
person would you like to make a donation
maybe one out of four to five times I
actually am asked although they're
required to make that request of people
who are checking out and he said well do
you think that really makes a difference
yes that definitely will make a
difference
more so than manipulating the size of
these donations will and I haven't
actually heard back from him yet whether
you know his attempts to sort of get
them more in the mode of asking were
effective but I was really struck by how
I thought he was focusing on the wrong
thing in terms of how to make this
program more effective in raising money
for food banks so I think that's part of
the application is how do we think about
the way in which the ask is made in
order to sort of get a more favorable
response to what we're trying to
accomplish okay a couple other things I
want to mention as extensions one is
what about the worst situation where you
have to go back and ask somebody for
something who's already told you no and
as I'm an editor of a journal right now
or like I said you know editor of a
journal where I have to ask reviewers to
review things who love to say no all the
time and I have to go back and ask them
repeatedly no seriously can you do it
this time and it's a terribly awkward
thing to do when somebody's already
rejected you to have to go back and ask
them again
but what is our expectation like are we
so averse that we always just sort of
sort those people out well I'm not going
to go back to those folks who've refused
me in the past are they actually less
likely to say yes in the future or maybe
are they more likely to say yes in the
future I would suggest that it's
actually hard for people to say no who
suggested before and they may in some
cases be more motivated to say yes the
second time around but my expectation is
the opposite because I think person who
says no once more likely to say no
second time so I definitely want to go
back to that person so we ran a couple
studies to look and see whether this was
the case whether people are pretty bad
at judging if past compliance is a good
predictor or past refusal is a good
predictor of future compliance and so we
asked people to make estimates of you
know what do you think the effect is
after we ask them to assume a role
either as a person who's asking someone
for help after having been refused or
being asked for help after having
refused someone what do you think the
likelihood is this person that you will
say yes or that this person will say yes
in response this request and what we
find is that people assume who are
adopting the sort of role as a help
seeker having to go back to somebody who
said no in the past that they are far
less likely to say yes they're more
likely to say no but the opposite is
true for those who are thinking about it
from the perspective of the person being
asked no I'd actually be more likely to
say yes if they came back to me after
I've already said no because I feel bad
about having said no in the past so my
temptation is person in this role is to
let's take this person out because I
don't want to go back to them again when
in reality they might actually be a
somewhat attractive ask for me so we
again tested this in a live
demonstration actually here on Stanford
campus in which we wanted to see if we
could get this effect in an actual
situation so we went to Tresidder Union
which is our sort of Student Union here
on campus and Dan nework who's worked
with us on this project had to stand
there in the middle of the Student Union
and as people were walking by asked him
to fill out a questionnaire and we were
only interested in the people who said
no basically to filling out the
questionnaire but enough people did
certainly the
we got a pretty good sample size and
what we did was after they said no I
won't fill out this questionnaire is Dan
asked them okay that's fine
but can you do me a favor can you take
this envelope and just mail it on your
way cuz if the post office is sort of
like on the way do you mind just
dropping it off in the mail for me and
we wanted to know in this case like what
percentage of people would say yes to a
follow up request after they just
refused a request and then also wanted
to see if people read about this
situation from the Dan's perspective or
read about the situation from the person
walking bys perspective what would their
estimates be and so when people read
about this situation from the
perspective of the helpseeker who's Dan
the graduate student they gave an
estimate of you know maybe thirty four
percent of people will say yes to that
follow-up request but when people read
about it from the perspective of the
person walking by they thought about
half a people would say yes to that
request big difference in terms of their
opinion having just sort of manipulated
that one aspect whose perspective are
you thinking about this from and in
reality it's about forty four percent so
these people are more accurate these
folks much less accurate under
estimating how likely somebody is to say
yes when they've said no before they
think that no is a pretty good predictor
of future knows if you've heard it once
you're going to hear it a second time so
maybe it's not worth it to you to go
back to people who've refused you in the
past so one of our sort of cautions we
would give is that it might be helpful
to think about a broadening pool of
people you can potentially ask for
resources a broadening pool that
includes those who've said no in the
past
sounds very counterintuitive I recognize
that but it actually might be something
that's effective the last set of studies
that I want to go through look at
another extension which is help-seeking
I've talked a lot about predicting help
helping but I want to talk about how
people predict help seeking and my
expectation is that the exact opposite
happens that whereas people
underestimate how likely people are to
say yes when they ask them for something
people grossly overestimate
likely others are to ask them for
something that is we think that maybe as
a manager it's great to have an
open-door policy because people will
gladly come in and ask us for assistance
whenever they need it but we are pretty
bad at overestimating how embolden
people will feel to come and ask for
assistance and in social support
organizations this is a huge issue
you know how much usage are you going to
get out of the services you offer so one
example of this I can think of is a
great meta-analysis of bullying studies
that was done in Europe which looked at
the success of bullying programs in
getting students in schools to use to
use the services that were offered and
sadly even though there's nothing wrong
with the program's themselves they were
actually pretty effective for the most
part in providing assistance a
staggeringly low number of students
would use them and of course they didn't
have any insight on why they weren't
using them they were too sort of
offering conjecture and of course what's
the first thing people think of why
they're not using them they must not
think it's very useful as opposed to I
would suggest is that they find it way
too awkward to go and ask for help with
being bullied but as the person who's
the one who could potentially help
someone we often think that instead it's
something about they don't see the
potential value in this help that I'm
offering them when really it's just it's
too darn hard or awkward to ask so in
this case we look at a pair of
situations in which people are in a role
where they're expected to provide help
one is our a our TAS for various courses
around campus everything from
Biosciences to the humanities and these
are all folks who are paid to be
teaching assistants and they have almost
all of them t8 classes before so they
have lots of experience in this role we
also took a sample of second year MBA
students who volunteered to be peer
advisors for first year MBA students in
this case it's really interesting
they're not being paid but they were
students themselves in the same
situation as first years the previous
year and we wanted to see you know over
the course of a semester how many times
they were approached for help and how
many times they assumed they thought
they would be approached for help
and so when we asked them this again
they grossly overestimated how likely
people were to come ask them for help
the mba students who had to track this
actually as part of their peer advising
program track how many students came and
asked them where as they thought about
14 or 15 students would come ask them
for help it was only closer to 7 or so
students who came and asked them but for
the TAS even though they were literally
teeing the same class the year before
again overestimated how many students
would come ask them for help or
assistance so what's going on here well
interestingly enough when we asked the
MBA students to explain why do you think
these folks didn't come to you for help
they said well what can I really do for
them I mean I can't really offer them
that much assistance you know to help
them out as opposed to it would be
really awkward for them to come ask me
now as first-year students when we
survey the first year students we asked
them why didn't you come use this
program or they said well it'd be really
hard for me to come ask a second-year
student for help or advice as opposed to
I didn't think it'd be that useful so
the person who's the helper thinks it's
all about perceived utility the person
who's the help seeker is just know it's
all about social awkwardness and so
they're just completely missing each
other in terms of what the how to make
the system work or to integrate it we
ran this scenario study in which we
wanted to see if we just got people to
think about being a help seeker think
about being a helper would we get the
same effect because you could imagine
there might be some self-selection bias
in that previous study and so we asked
some your holiday fee do you think it is
an individual would ask for help in a
simple sort of scenario situation where
they were in need of help and sure
enough you know these are just simple
equal status situations you have to go
ask a colleague or a peer for some
advice whatever the case might be and in
this situation when they're asked to
think about the perspective of the
person who provide help they think it's
far more likely that the person will ask
for it then if they're asked to think
about the situation from the perspective
the person in need of help what explains
this is their perceived discomfort how
hard is it how awkward is it
uncomfortable is it embarrassing is it
to ask somebody for help the person
who's thinking about it from the role of
the helper says not nearly as
embarrassing as people who are thinking
about it from the role that helps
think it is so if that actually explains
our effect that they're not judging
awkwardness they're not judging social
factors nearly are weighing them nearly
enough and thinking about what prevents
people from asking for assistance we
design one last study in which we looked
at sort of like it may be an
intervention here or think about an
intervention in an organization that had
a mentoring program and so we were
trying to sort of manipulate a couple
different things here are you thinking
about this from the perspective of the
person who needs help or the person who
can provide sorry person who can provide
help or the person who needs help in
this mentoring program manipulate their
perspective but then also manipulate
whether or not the encouragement to
participate in the mentoring program
focuses more on the instrumental
benefits they can get out of it or
focuses more on downplaying the social
costs of being in this mentoring program
and so it's either sort of saying things
like mentorship will really help your
career versus you really won't be
bothering me and so when we run these
conditions what we expect to find is
that mentors are going to think that the
really effective approach is the one
that focuses on the instrumental
benefits you want to get people to ask
for help tell them how great help will
be and you will get them to ask for help
but in reality it's the downplaying of
social costs it gets people to ask and
that's we sort of wrote out this sort of
fake memo to them and that's exactly
what we find this flip such that when we
emphasize the comfort rather than
discomfort of help seeking the people in
the potential those in need of help a
new higher role are emboldened to ask
for help but those who are in the mentor
role think know the way to go is to
focus on those instrumental benefits and
so it's just completely missing the boat
here in terms of what's driving behavior
in this social support program that you
know this social support programs going
to work because I focus on encouraging
people to think about how much they're
going to get out of it as opposed to
focusing up on getting them in the door
okay again sort of the same explanation
in terms of the perceived awkwardness
they just don't see it as awkward when
they're thinking about it from the
helpers' role but of course it's so
awkward for the people who are thinking
about you
effective interestingly enough when we
asked them to cope with attributions for
what's going on here
when they see low rates of usage those
in the role of the mentor think that
while they must our thought was very
valuable as opposed to they must have
felt it was awkward to ask for help but
the reverse is true for those who are in
the position of needing help so I think
there's a lot of potentially important
insights in the context of asking people
for stuff largely because so much of
what people have to do in human services
organisations or other types of
nonprofit and public service
organisations is to ask people for stuff
or to get other people to ask for stuff
or to somehow get other people to ask
for help themselves but a lot of those
barriers to asking for help or agreeing
to help aren't necessarily well
understood and so the interventions we
designed to increase helping behavior
should be tweaked so that they're
actually more in line with what those
social or psychological barriers might
look like okay so I'll stop there any
cool take a few questions ready go
thanks very much by the way okay yeah
well you studies about the
attractiveness and we sort of made a
joke but it's certainly the
attractiveness of the questioner sure
affecting the outcome have you
controlled for that other than trying to
make sure that I don't have well I don't
have just one person asking who might be
like high or low or on attractiveness
but just have lots of different people
sort of posing these requests and we
don't find in cases where of course
allow these studies or have random
assignment we don't find much evidence
to suggest that's really what's
explaining our effect but I do remember
one case where I had so I ran this one
study in Penn Station which I really
like a lot but haven't been able to
publish but I really enjoy this studies
I'm going to share and it looks at
scripts in helping or asking for help in
which you know one of the most popular
scripts we use is can you do me a favor
before we ask somebody for something and
in this particular case we stop people
who are looking for waiting for a train
and Penn Station
probably the worst place you could stop
somebody in New York City right and ask
them to fill out a just a short one page
questionnaire and in this case 54% of
people who were asked to fill out the
questionnaire agreed to which my wife's
response was which one of your female
doctoral students was doing this study
um because she really wanted to know
which one it was but but the reality was
the condition we were really interested
in was not when they were being a so in
this case I should back up 54% of those
were asked directly would you fill out
this questionnaire agree to do it but
when we threw in that little script can
you do me a favor pause wait for the
response would you fill out a
questionnaire 87% agreed to do it so
huge increase not personal connection
its commitment so what's the modal
response when somebody asks you can you
give me a favor
any guesses yep they say yeah sure what
is it that's the most common response
which is funny because they don't say
what is it yeah sure they say yeah sure
what is it that's the classic example of
pre commitment right there I don't know
what it is but sure I'll do it then it's
really hard to say I was just kidding I
really don't want to help you out all
you know you can't you can't really undo
that situation very easily and so if
you're like sure I'll do the
questionnaire it's a very sort of simple
demonstration of a principle like that
that seems so subtle because it's just a
very simple little group wrote script
that we use yeah either for profit or
nonprofit organizations either these
pictures of phone banks of people making
cold calls out into the night and either
saying I've got a great investment for
you or I mean the policeman's Union
helping you know crippled children or
whatever it is that's out there that
they are fine out of what their hit rate
is right do you know has anyone ever
yeah come back to you what's surprising
is that they're higher than you think or
higher than you would think right and
part of its that and they do use this
kind of commitment and consistency
approach to encouraging people to donate
and a funny thing is I always tell this
story in class the funny thing is is I I
study this stuff for a living and yet
I'm still susceptible to it's still
vulnerable to it which suggests
something about me as a researcher I
don't know what it is but I can't learn
from my own work because I remember God
is
four years ago I was a in my apartment
in New York I got a call from one of
these folks and caught me a little off
guard I was doing something else pick up
the phone and they say excuse me I was
the police like it just gets your
attention immediately the police what
can I do for you his eyes want to ask
you a few questions do you have a minute
I said sure absolutely its police of
course I got a people action so so I
says you know he's only he says do you
live in a safe neighborhood I said yeah
I live in Lincoln Center he has a safe
neighborhood sure do you think the
police help make the neighborhood safe
really like we asked their job sure is
I'm sure they help make neighborhoods
safe no doubt do you think the police
should be recognized for the good work
they do to help make the neighborhoods
safe and I'm like yes should like we're
raising money for the policemen's ball
would you be willing to buy two tickets
for $50 and of course I'm like god damn
walked right into that one and of course
I'm like yes where's my checkbook
absolutely part of that because I don't
want to piss off the police in my
neighborhood but part of that is really
hard to say no in that situation and so
a lot of these attempts no matter how I
guess like protected people feel these
influence attempts can actually be
pretty effective when the directness is
increased and it just becomes really
hard for people to say no yeah evidence
about what happens to relationships
between an Oscar and a ski after you've
had a situation where you've done that
kind of influencing where you want to
maintain positive relationships and
positive impressions afterwards
absolutely depends on what to ask is
right so if you're asking somebody to
donate to charity that's different than
if you're asking somebody to sabotage an
organization or something right this is
a big key element and we're focusing of
course on good things a pro-social
behaviors in all of our contexts so
that's a that's a big difference but
yeah we'd be concerned about whether or
not what we're asking people to do well
we're asking them to shame others into
providing help or assistance you know
this sort of like trapped them into
doing good things and we're we're
worried about eliciting some enmity on
the part of others right when we do that
I don't think that necessarily happens
as often as we worry it does my sense is
that one of my favorite old studies was
this one study done in the 60s by pair
of psychologists named Jagger and Landy
and they were just trying to demonstrate
this principle of cognitive dissonance
but they did this great study in which
they had people who really didn't want
to provide help to one individual
provide help to them anyway and as it
turns out the effect that that has on
them is it increases their liking for
that individual they didn't really want
to help that person out in the first
place they you know weren't necessarily
highly motivated to do it but when they
were asked to do it and they did it the
fact that they did it made them much
more positively predisposed toward that
person view them more favorably
supported the cause more that sort of
thing and so you know part of its
whether or not the alignment between the
behavior we're trying to elicit and the
goals we're trying to accomplish her
there and I think that you know that is
often there enough of it is there that
makes that concern about eliciting
enmity a little bit less of a concern
for me yeah a lot of you since we were
in the business of asking a lot of
favors all right right so I edited a
magazine much of the content tip which
is volunteer generated so and it's a
very difficult thing to do and so I'm
asking I have a relationship with a
person where I'm asking him or her a lot
of favors we have very very strong norms
in our culture about asking favours
there's enormous of sufficiency that
Kathleen's research that weighs it on
norms about reciprocity and normally so
and also you know supposed to really ask
someone a favor unless you really really
need it and also you're supposed to
reciprocate so my question is I mean you
you do more than a lot of researchers
and that you go and show you can
actually ask two times and then that
increases the likelihood of the second
ask getting a yes but for those of us
who are asking like 20 times like what
is it blow up they have caller ID I'm
pretty sure they can just like not pick
up the phone I think if they see your
number
what's wrong for the most part often
people don't say no alone they say no
because so there's a lot of information
and that no because that tells you
whether or not it's maybe encouraging a
you know a future asks oh no because I'd
have no interest in doing that or no
because I can't right now no because I'm
constrained in some way you can imagine
going back to that person when those
constraints are lifted and they're
probably more likely to say yes so part
of its like sort of reading the
information they're giving you in the no
itself a lot of nose can be emphatic and
others can be more apologetic yeah they
just want to ask a question about
general calls for action and it's
specifically not going to volunteer
action there are obviously we have a
president right now who's very
interested in civic engagement things
and the lots of conversations in
Washington about what what's an
effective call to action it seems to me
from your research you'd suggest that a
general call to get involved go out do
something good is going to be less
effective than a specific call to action
to sign up to be a mentor in your school
is that yes or no where I'll say that's
neither okay I said either directness of
the request okay the Obama you know
movement showed us is that small group
organizing is incredibly effective or
asks so when you're having like groups
of individual smaller groups of
individuals make requests themselves of
other individuals they know doing so
directly actually being coached on how
to do that providing the materials that
would help them do that that becomes an
overwhelmingly effective method rather
than using some much more sort of
distant approach of getting that that
asked across I mean they really sort of
thought I think pretty carefully about
how to make this more of a home run in
their efforts so I'm eating into Adams
time right now so it'd be really
conscientious about that and I just want
to say thank you very much again for
your time today and happy to talk to you
later
you